Near-death experiences, hypothermia,
and an icebreaker no one saw coming. Oh,
and then there was that time
the whole crew was drugged.
One of the most bizarre things to happen on the
"Titanic" set happened while filming the framing
narrative centered around Bill Paxton's character
Brock Lovett and his search of the wreck of the
Titanic. Marilyn McAvoy — a background painter
who worked on "Titanic" — spoke to Vice about
the incident, which occurred in 1996 when some
cast and crew sat down to enjoy a clam chowder
lunch. There was only one problem: It was
spiked with PCP. Those affected — including
James Cameron and actor Bill Paxton — were rushed
to the hospital. Both Kate Winslet and Leonardo
DiCaprio were spared this eventful dinner, since
they weren't required for this Canadian shoot.
"And he said, 'Well did you eat the clam chowder?'
And I thought, 'Well yeah, I had a couple of
bowls,' and about that time I started feeling it."
Marilyn McAvoy recalls how the evening began,
with people going for seconds and thirds of the
chowder because it tasted so good. Everyone was
having a lot more than they usually would. Soon
people started tripping, and once they realized
what was happening, Cameron allegedly went up to
his room to make himself throw up and stop the
hallucinogen from taking over. McAvoy described
how the crew was in the hospital all night, as
some people were having a bad trip. She said,
"It became pretty chaotic. ... People had
a lot of energy. Some were in wheelchairs,
flying down the hallways. ...
People were playing hacky sack."
Bill Paxton also opened up to
Larry King about the incident,
describing the hospital scene
that night in much the same way.
"You see some people are freaking out, some people
are congo dancing, some people -
"What happened to you?"
are euphoric."
"I knew I was pretty stoned."
On her end, McAvoy said it all seemed
like a dream, and that her experience
wasn't too bad. Unfortunately for the
crew, they never caught the perpetrator,
resulting in that entire night going down
as one of the weirdest on-set moments.
Once the Titanic sinks, Jack freezes in the
frigid waters, but Rose manages to stay alive
and flag down a nearby boat looking
for survivors. It's a tragic ending,
but Rose's shivering tears weren't pure
acting. It was cold as hell in that water.
In 2017, Kate Winslet appeared on
"The Late Show With Stephen Colbert"
and revealed that when shooting this
scene in the water, she got hypothermia.
"Yeah, I was really f—ing cold!"
She further explained that, even though this
was all supposed to be pretend movie magic,
there was so much water that the
crew couldn't heat it all up. Hey,
maybe if DiCaprio had just climbed up on
that piece of wood to keep her warm… nah,
nevermind. There's no way there
was room for him. No possible way.
It turns out, Kate Winslet suffered quite
a bit during filming. In a 1997 interview
with The Los Angeles Times, Winslet revealed
a variety of injuries she got on set: bruises,
gashes, and a chipped elbow. She also described
the moment when she almost drowned during one
scene. What makes this even more bizarre
is the fact that Cameron didn't notice
and kept directing, as he was completely
oblivious to her near-death experience.
The scene in question takes place when Rose
and Jack are running through the ship as
water is gushing in. They try to find an escape
route, but soon get trapped in by a closed gate,
with water pouring in on them. Once the scene
was cut, the production team opened the gate
to allow DiCaprio and Winslet through. However,
her coat got caught on the iron bars and she was
submerged in the water. Winslet described the
experience to The Los Angeles Times, saying,
"I had no breath left. I thought
I'd burst. And Jim just said,
'OK, let's go again.' That was his attitude. I
didn't want to be a wimp so I didn't complain."
"Well, I'm fine. I'll be fine, really."
Although Cameron realized a few minutes
later that Winslet was feeling shaken by
the experience, he wanted to get back
into it and shoot the scene again,
comparing it to getting back on a horse
after a fall. The show must go on, after all.
For many, the staircase in "Titanic" is an iconic
symbol of Rose and Jack's love. Early in the film,
Jack waits for Rose at the bottom of
the staircase to escort her to dinner
with her family. He's blown away when
he sees her looking fancy and beautiful,
and the romantic tension between them is
palpable. In the final scene of the movie,
Rose passes away and the staircase appears
again, reuniting her with Jack and all of the
others lost on the Titanic. Both are beautiful
and emotional moments, as they show the journey
of Jack and Rose's relationship, culminating
with their final embrace in the afterlife.
However, behind the scenes of this
romantic tale is a puzzling story.
In 2017, Cameron reflected on his time filming
"Titanic" in National Geographic's "Titanic:
20 Years Later with James Cameron." When looking
back at the iconic staircase, Cameron recalled,
"The staircase has got a steel footing, then
when we sank the ship, it lifted. Wood is
buoyant. It ripped off that footing and it
all floated up, and it actually pinned two
stunt players. Fortunately, they weren't
hurt, but it was a pretty scary moment."
The staircase was built to replicate
the actual grand stairs that were
aboard the famous vessel, so perhaps it
brought some of its bad luck with it.
Brett Baker — Leonardo DiCaprio's photo
double in "Titanic" — spoke to Vanity Fair
in 2016 about his experience making the film.
Baker was a struggling actor and was thrilled
to join the project, even though the role wasn't
exactly what he'd trained for. As a photo double,
Baker's job was to silently take DiCaprio's
place in shots where you couldn't see his face
to give the star a break from more tedious work.
Baker's presence in "Titanic" is undetectable, but
he remembers how nervous he was to meet Cameron
for the first time since he is both shorter and
older than DiCaprio. Luckily, Cameron believed he
looked enough like DiCaprio that it would work.
Baker looks back fondly on his time on the
"Titanic" set, saying most actors don't get
their big break starring in one of the biggest
films of all time. Plus, the photo double life got
interesting thanks to all of the teen fans waiting
by the studio gate, hoping to catch a glimpse of
DiCaprio. During the filming of "Titanic," the
Leo-craze was in full swing. Security would usher
DiCaprio out the back to avoid the fans, and Baker
would be brought out front for everyone to gush
over, turning him into a real-life photo double
for the star. As Baker recalled to Vanity Fair,
"[The fans] went berserk. Screaming, looking
inside the window, waving their pieces of
paper for an autograph. ... I don't know if anyone
knew that was going on at the gate every morning."
At least he got his own little
fan club during filming.
Actors have been known to take things from
set from time to time. Think of it less as
stealing and more as holding on to a piece of
memorabilia that commemorates the time they
spent filming. It's understandable
when one goes through blood, sweat,
and tears to make a film that they
feel like they deserve a little
something for their troubles ... aside
from their massive paycheck, of course.
Winslet did almost drown and get hypothermia.
Maybe it's fair to say that she wanted to take
a little something extra on the way out.
In an interview with The New York Times,
she revealed that she likes
saving things from sets,
and during "Titanic," she snagged
some jewelry. She explained,
"I did take a pair of Rose's
earrings, but somewhere I lost one."
It's a fitting story, since "Titanic"
itself is framed around a search for lost
jewelry – a necklace that, of course,
gets lost in the ocean at the end.
It's no secret that Leonardo DiCaprio and
Kate Winslet have enjoyed a decades-long
friendship. Ever since starring as
star-crossed lovers in "Titanic,"
the two have freely shown each other their
admiration and support over the years. A
decade after "Titanic," the two starred in the
post-war romantic drama "Revolutionary Road."
Winslet talked about her friendship with
DiCaprio in an interview with The Guardian,
noting that they've known each other
for half their lives. She said,
"He's my friend, my really close
friend. We're bonded for life."
Winslet won the Golden Globe
for Best Actress in 2009 for
"Revolutionary Road" and gushed about
her co-star in her off-the-cuff speech.
For his part, DiCaprio has described
how Winslet broke the ice between the
two right off the bat. In the official
behind-the-scenes book of the film,
Ed W. Marsh's "James Cameron's Titanic," DiCaprio
shared their bizarre first encounter that did
just that. The first scene he shot was the one
where he draws naked Rose. DiCaprio explained,
"[Winslet] had no shame with it ... She wanted to
break the ice a little beforehand, so she flashed
me. I wasn't prepared for that, so she had one
up on me. I was pretty comfortable after that."
A 1998 Rolling Stone profile on Winslet
detailed how things snowballed from there,
with Winslet and DiCaprio spending the
rest of the shoot pranking each other
and forming a very comfortable
relationship. Winslet explained,
"We were kind of the two goofy kids
on the set [...] We’d do the most
ridiculous things to each other.
He’d be tickling me, groping me,
winding me up. And I’d be doing the same
thing back, sort of grabbing his bum."
DiCaprio discussed the seriousness of
their friendship on set as well, saying,
"She was my best friend for seven months. We’d
unload the stresses of the shoot to each other,
vent to each other, watch out for each other. Kate
was just the perfect person to work with
because she was very much one of the guys,
and it would have been much harder
without her. We were partners."
"Oh that was better. You gotta work on it. Really
try and hawk it up and get some
body to it. You know, you gotta…"